so it turns out the prey Predator movie
isn't just going to get a sequel it was
always planned to be part of a trilogy
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so if you are a regular Sidetrack you'll
know that I do speak to a couple of
people that work within the industry not
hype Executives they're all people that
have quite normal boring jobs within the
film and TV industry but they get to
tell me lots of Juicy bits of
information and I've been told something
very interesting about the prey movie
so it was obvious from the end of the
movie that there was going to be some
sort of sequel at very least we see the
adolini flintlock pistol the pistol that
we then see in Predator 2 still with
nauru so
it makes sense that there's going to be
another film because we've got to find
out how that pistol gets back into the
hands of the Predators right also the
ending sequence the cartoon sequence
actually shows predatorships arriving so
it's not really a massive shock that
generally the gist within the industry
is that a sequel is definitely on the
way but speaking to people that I know
they've actually been telling me that
Dan Trachtenberg actually always has had
a Trilogy in mind this is always going
to be part of three films and that Naru
would star throughout those films
now generally speaking prey did very
very well it's got a really good
critical response
um and most of the fans really loved it
a lot of people shouted woke at it how
can a 90 pound girl defeat a predator
and all that which was a bit
disappointing and also other people did
point out that the predator in this film
seemed like a bit of a [ __ ] you know
killing snakes and things it doesn't
seem like the brightest predator in the
world but it was obviously a new Hunter
it was probably like a juvenile Predator
that's how I always thought it but it
was still a significantly powerful
animal and
you know nauru took him down in a very
intelligent clever way for me it's a
very grounded movie I really liked how
they used the Predator Zone sort of like
weakness against it you know that it
ignored nauru at times because she
wasn't considered a threat and that that
arrogance came round and bit The
Predator firmly in the ass in the end so
a sequel obviously on the cards but a
Trilogy and I've been told what roughly
that trilogy might look like
don't forget that if you enjoy the
content you can hit the join button and
become a fully fledged side tracker that
really helps out the channel you can go
to scygashtrack.com there's loads of
like merchandise things on there and a
load of new designs coming very soon
also if you are new to the channel don't
forget to like subscribe and hit the
Bell notifications so you miss none of
our new videos as well as the Sidetrack
sides Channel
so I've been told that Dan Trachtenberg
from the outset was looking to turn
narrow into a warrior a warrior that the
Predators would Revere for 250 years
while they hold on to the Memento the
flintlock pistol that they then finally
did to give to Danny Glover's character
and Predator 2. it was obviously a prize
to the Predators that they were handing
over something that was very important
to them the whole point of this Trilogy
will be to explain that so we see from
the beginning of this film that narrow
is a skill tracker at the start of the
film she's not the greatest Huntress in
the world she you know misses a deer or
two but by the end of the movie really
hungs the skills and even though she
says I might not be the greatest hunter
I do know how to survive and she shows
that more and more throughout the movie
by the end of the movie she really has
blossomed into the warrior that we want
to see in the next part of the movie but
she will need to go for further than
that and from what I'm told the second
movie will all be about testing nauru
further that the Predators are going to
come
impressed by what they've seen to now
but to see whether she could be the
warrior they want now we know from the
greater law of the Predators or the
yacha that actually they will blood
other beings other themselves that
they're in the comics etc etc humans
have been blooded and become Predators
themselves
that actually the Predator monocle is
not about actual the being the creature
the animal it's more about the attitude
and the spirit within the person now
Maru is not going to survive all three
movies is what I'm being told and in the
third movie she will lose her life but
she will lose her life in a way that the
Predators 100 respect she won't just
become another blooded Predator that
they fight alongside she'll actually
become something that the Archer Revere
she will become a proper like Warrior
Princess Xena style you're breaking my
heart
I'm also told that at some point in
these movies I'm not 100 certain whether
it's going to be in the second or the
third movie that there's going to sort
of be a little bit of an AVP
build a thing going on and we are
actually going to see a version of the
Xenomorph alien from the aliens
franchise now I'm told we're going to
see a version of because Dan
Trachtenberg is trying to create
something that is slightly separate from
the predator and that have come before
and he would do the same with the alien
franchise and Hulu and Disney are more
than happy for him to do that
considering the success that prey has
already had so we will see aliens now I
do wonder how this could be related to
the aliens TV series that is coming next
year
I don't know if there is going to be a
connection there for certain but it
would be interesting to find out and
hopefully we will know by the end of
next year but having a proper AVP
because I mean Alien versus Predator
that should have been brilliant that
film the game was Ace the whole setup
for AVP completely makes sense that the
Predators would hunt down the Xenomorphs
please
I love that these things could come
together Disney owned both franchises so
it's something that completely happened
um it's just whether down Trachtenberg
can pull the magic out a second time and
do this in a way that is still grounded
and still realistic because for me that
was really the joy of prey is that he
kept it sort of grounded and that it was
believable once you get your head past
that she's a girl
which people seem to really focus on the
film was realistic in the way she fought
back
I can completely see how Nuru defeated
the Predator she defeated the Predator
because the Predator didn't take her
seriously as a threat and as I said
earlier she used that to her advantage
an alien xenomorph won't do that and
Aliens xenomorph will just see her as
lunch so how are they going to have that
battle where nauru survives that
conflict I'm not sure now my source has
heard bits and Bobs about this but he
doesn't know the full outline for the
full three films obviously they haven't
been written yet
but then Trachtenberg has got apparently
a idea in mind and it's something that
he's talked to lots of people about
apparently over the last few years
because this idea has been brewing his
mind for a while
but it would make sense to me
there's some sort of AVP storyline was
going to be in the next movie where the
Predators come back to earth finds naaru
are impressed by her but want to test it
to see whether she really is the warrior
they hope she is
they will test it in lots of different
ways but I imagine the ultimate test
would be her against a Xenomorph so
maybe that would be in the second one or
maybe that is in the third movie because
again if the greater law is that the
Predators consider this even more for
alien to be sort of like the ultimate
prey so maybe that is what we'll walk up
to by the third movie and that it's
actually there that nauru does then
eventually lose her life but loses a
life in such a way that earns her such
respect that the Predators hold on to
that pistol for 250 years before another
human being comes along that can stand
up to them and earns their respect in a
similar way but what do you think guys
what do you think about this idea of
doing a Trilogy do you think there is a
risk that this film could wander into
the silly
um he kept such a good job of keeping it
just this side of silly I am worried
about that the first movie really did
earn a lot of respect and I'm worried
that it could lose some of that if the
film became a comic book movie by the
third one
damn tractorberg is going to be very
careful in the way he tones this but
what do you think get in the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content don't forget to
hit the join button because that really
supports the channel as always guys
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]